there are no survivors after authorities
say a small plane crashed into another
plane this afternoon madison kimbrough
joins us live near rancho and carey
tonight with the details madison
the crash happened right behind me as
you're about to see here at north las
vegas airport now the federal aviation
administration says there were two
people aboard each plane and according
to the north las vegas fire department a
total of four people like you mentioned
are dead
the faa says two small single engine
planes crashed around noon sunday while
one was preparing to land at the north
las vegas airport they say the crash
happened in the field east of runway 30
and one of the planes fell into a water
retention pond local pilot dory rodin is
an avid flyer and he says he flies at
least once a week out of north las vegas
airport i have my plane hangard here and
there's a lot of traffic so it's always
a concern about you know how well the
airport system and
flights are managed coming in and out of
the airport my flight instructor
indicated that she knows the couple that
owns the piper meridian yes the north
las vegas airport is open for air
traffic at this time
it's still unknown what caused the crash
but again north las vegas fire
department confirming that four people
are dead their identities at this time
are unknown live in north las vegas
madison kimbrough live local now